I was walking with ilila on the strip
and some guy bumped into her or
something and he was like watch yourself
skinny like he said that to her and she
was like you think I'm skinny like she
said it like half jokingly to me
afterwards we just obviously kept
walking but I thought it was such an
interesting thing is that he meant it as
an insult she chose to take it as a
compliment which then meant that like
all of the like these things that we you
know we toss at one another it's like
it's only because we choose to accept
that it's an insult that it becomes
insulting like I'm sure someone at some
point in your life has said something
something that they intended to insult
you with and you're like oh well that's
not that's not that bad I'm actually
kind of okay with that if I can make
that thing okay one time then I can do
that every time because it's literally
just a choice on how I want to perceive
it